Hey, ocean, what’s with all the salt?
Hi everyone, Julian here for DNews at YouTube
Space LA.
Recently we got a question from NENE71984
asking why the oceans were salty, and everyone
in the office kind of looked at each other
and went, “Yeah, why?”
I’m going to assume she’s not asking why
the ocean is all sassy and bitter, but instead
is asking why there’s salt in the oceans
but not in our lakes and streams.
Except some lakes like the Great Salt Lake,
I know, people in Utah and internet trolls.
Jeez, I always have to be technically correct
with you guys, the best kind of correct.
First off the salt in the oceans is 90% the
same chemical makeup as your table salt, good
old NaCl.
Sodium Chloride isn’t the only kind of salt
there is, there are many varieties because
a salt is just a compound held together by
an ionic bond.
What happens is an atom steals an electron
from another and becomes negatively charged
or an anion.
Then it’s attracted to the positive cation
and the two atoms bond.
So a lot of different chemicals can come together
and make salts, and because of this the ocean
salt is also made of a little magnesium, calcium,
potassium, and a polyatomic anion made of
sulfur and 4 oxygens called sulfate.
But how does the salt get there?
From the rocks on land, actually.
According to the US Geological Survey, dissolved
CO2 in rainwater makes it slightly acidic,
eroding rocks when it falls.
That’s not the only trick water has up its
sleeve.
And H2O molecule is polar, the oxygen atom
hogs the electrons so it’s more negatively
charged on one side and more positively charged
by the hydrogen atoms.
When salts are in water, they break apart
because the only thing holding them in their
crystalline shape was that ionic attraction.
Once the rain lands, it flows downhill, carrying
the dissolved minerals and ions to streams
and lakes and rivers and eventually the oceans.
The USGS also points out salt comes from inside
the ocean too.
Volcanoes and hydrothermal vents heat water
so it can dissolve some of the basalt on the
ocean floor, adding salt to the mix.
But why does the ocean stay salty?
Because salt has been accumulating there faster
than it leaves.
Some organisms use the salt or the basalt
on the ocean floor takes some back, but the
exchange rate isn’t even.
There’s also the factor of evaporation.
When water evaporates, the molecules spread
farther apart and the magnetic pull from the
vapor isn’t enough to bring the ions with
them.
As a result, the salt stays behind and it
rains fresh water.
So long as the water doesn’t get stuck inland
a la the Great Salt lake, salinity levels
will stay below .05%, compared to the 3.5%
average salinity of
the oceans.